[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i am here today to show the scientists
that we care
we're worried about our future we have
to change our future because we have the
data
science have the data we could be part
of the solution and engineers can be
part of this solution need to
acknowledge that a culture that is based
on
continuous consumption and increasing
consumption
is not one that will be around for very
long
[Music]
it's very important to understand that
we scientists we need to tell things
the way they are we have to stop to be
quiet about the problems politicians
both need
to know that there's a public mandate
and that's what these strikes do
and then they also need people with
expertise in economics and climate
policy and climate science to help them
design the best policies to do so
and so i'm hoping that through being a
activist and a researcher i can engage
in both those areas
we don't have a single person coming
from the sciences sitting on the united
states sciences
so if we're going to talk about anything
from climate change to addressing
things like data security and cyber
security we have to have people from the
sciences and stem fields
scientific research helps us to get a
better
[Music]
life quality science data are important
and science data are saying that we are
the climate crisis
crisis
i want the media the general
public all the people who have the power
to do more about climate change to
understand that this is an urgent issue
now and we really need to take more
action this is the most important thing
that's happening to us
every single student every single young
person every single
old person on the planet london can't do
it on its own
the uk can't do it on its own europe can
do it on its own
we all need to get together as a planet
and act collectively
people are suffering people are dying
entire ecosystems are collapsing
we are in the beginning of a mass
extinction
and all you can talk about is money and
fairy tales of eternal economic growth
how dare you
the world is waking up and change
is coming whether you like it or not
you